Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
加拿大油砂开采产生了大量的碳排放。因此，六家最大的公司携手合作，在迈向净零排放的道路上大步迈进。投资于技术和创新。每桶碳排放量平均已经减少了22%。与政府合作创造和保护就业机会。正在开发世界上最大的碳捕集与封存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在实施中，我们正通过多种途径取得进展。请访问 pathwaysalliance.ca 查看我们的行动计划。
Music On Tuesday the 2nd of November 1999 Donna Wheeler was murdered in her home at Biralla in western Sydney. But who was responsible? Was it her ex-husband John who found a body and alerted the police? Was it her violent ex-boyfriend Keith who was recently charged for assaulting Donna? Keith wouldn't have been happy that Donna was spending a lot of time with his brother Colin since they separated. Speaking of Colin, he was seen with Donna on the night of her murder. And then there was the phone call she received from a mail caller asking to meet him that night.
音乐 1999年11月2日，星期二，唐娜·惠勒（Donna Wheeler）在悉尼西部比拉拉（Biralla）的家中被谋杀。但凶手是谁？是发现尸体并报警的前夫约翰（John）吗？是最近因殴打唐娜而被起诉的暴力前男友基思（Keith）吗？基思肯定不会高兴看到唐娜自从他们分居后，花了很多时间和他弟弟科林（Colin）在一起。说到科林，有人看到他在谋杀当晚和唐娜在一起。然后，她还接到一个神秘男电话，要求当晚见面。
Music Donna Wheeler was 30 years old at the time of her death in 1999. She lived at Kingsland Road in Biralla which is west of the Sydney city area. She was a bright and sparkly person who was well liked by everybody. She had a lot of friends and they described her as a beautiful, caring and loving person. She had one son from a previous marriage who was age 12 at the time. She was an excellent mother, very loving and supportive of her son. The first Tuesday of November is the day that a horse race stops Australia.
音乐 唐娜·惠勒在1999年去世时年仅30岁。她住在比拉拉的金斯兰路（Kingsland Road），该地位于悉尼市区以西。她是一个开朗、闪耀且深受所有人喜爱的人。她有很多朋友，他们将她形容为一个美丽、有爱心且充满关爱的人。她与前夫育有一子，当时12岁。她是一位出色的母亲，对儿子充满爱心和支持。11月的第一周星期二是让整个澳大利亚为之停滞的赛马日。
Melbourne Cup Day, the day that everybody becomes a horse racing expert. It's the biggest race of the year. The night before the cup Donna had been having a few drinks with Colin Bond at the Regents Park Hotel, one of the local watering holes. Donna had become friends with Colin through her ex-boyfriend Keith Bond. Keith and Colin were brothers who lived together at Amy Street in Regents Park. Only a few minutes drive from Donna's house at Biralla. Donna had only split up with Keith a few weeks before. It was described as a volatile, violent relationship.
墨尔本杯赛马日，这一天每个人都成了赛马专家。这是全年中最大规模的赛马比赛。杯赛前夕，唐娜和科林·邦德（Colin Bond）在当地的聚会场所之一摄政公园酒店（Regents Park Hotel）喝了几杯。唐娜是通过前男友基思·邦德认识科林的。基思和科林是兄弟，住在摄政公园的艾米街（Amy Street）。距离唐娜在比拉拉的家只有几分钟的车程。唐娜和基思分手才几周。这段关系被形容为充满变数和暴力。
At times they would get on and everything would be fine, but Keith wanted more than Donna was willing to give him, and this upset Keith. Keith wanted a serious relationship with Donna. He constantly professed his love for her and said he wanted to get married and have kids. Donna tried to get it through Keith's head that she had just come out of a marriage and she really wasn't looking to settle down into another serious relationship. She wasn't looking for a partner, she had been there and done it, she just wanted to be friends. Keith couldn't accept that and it was the cause of a lot of fights between them. It was when one of these fights turned physical that the relationship ended. Keith struck Donna hard causing her front tooth to break.
有时他们相处得很好，一切都很正常，但基思想要的远超唐娜愿意给他的，这让基思感到沮丧。基思想要和唐娜建立认真的恋爱关系。他不断表白自己对她的爱，说想结婚生子。唐娜试图让基思明白，她刚结束一段婚姻，真的不想那么快安定下来开始另一段严肃的感情。她并不想找伴侣，她经历过也做过了，她只想做朋友。基思无法接受这一点，这也是他们之间发生多次争吵的原因。正是其中一次争吵升级为肢体冲突时，这段感情走到了尽头。基思狠狠地打了唐娜，导致她的门牙断裂。
The police were called and Keith was arrested and charged for assault. An apprehended violence order, what some would know as a restraining order, was taken out to keep Keith away from Donna. But a piece of paper wasn't going to stop Keith, he was obsessed. Not long after that Donna woke up to find the tires on her car had been slashed. Keith was the prime suspect but of course nobody saw anything so it couldn't be proven. Since Donna had split with Keith she had become a lot closer to his brother Colin and they spent a lot of time together. Keith wasn't overly impressed with this. So it was that night, the 1st of November 1999, the eve of Melbourne Cup Day, that Donna gave Colin $20 to put a bet on for her on the big race.
警察被叫来，基思被捕并被控袭击罪。为了让基思远离唐娜，法院颁布了一项限制暴力令（即人们所熟知的禁制令）。但一张纸是阻止不了基思的，他已经着魔了。没过多久，唐娜醒来发现自己汽车的轮胎被划破了。基思是头号嫌疑人，但当然没有人看到任何东西，所以无法证明。自从唐娜与基思分手后，她与基思的弟弟科林走得更近了，他们花了很多时间在一起。基思对此并不是特别高兴。就在1999年11月1日那一晚，也就是墨尔本杯赛马日前夕，唐娜给了科林20美元，让他帮自已在大赛中下注。
She wanted $10 each way on the Bart Cummings trained horse, Rogan Josh. And what happened that next day? Donna had done it, she picked the winner. She couldn't enjoy it straight away though, she was at work, but once she finished her shift she made her way to the Regents Park Hotel. She got there just after 6pm when she met Colin, who had been there drinking most of the day. Colin handed over Donna's winnings and then they shared a few drinks together in celebration. A little while later they decided to change location and go to the Regents Park bowling club. This might have had something to do with the fact that Keith had just turned up to the Regents Park Hotel.
她想要各压10美元买巴特·卡明斯（Bart Cummings）训练的马“罗甘乔什”（Rogan Josh）。第二天发生了什么？唐娜竟然赢了，她选中了冠军。不过她没能立刻享受这份喜悦，因为她还在上班，但一旦结束轮班，她就赶往了摄政公园酒店。她在傍晚6点刚过到达那里，遇到了已经在那里喝了一整天酒的科林。科林把唐娜赢得的奖金交给了她，然后两人一起喝了几杯以示庆祝。过了一会儿，他们决定换个地方，去摄政公园保龄球俱乐部。这可能与基思刚刚出现在摄政公园酒店有关。
They played the poker machines and had a few more drinks at the bowling club. Not long after that Donna received a call from her ex husband John. John had their 12 year old son at the time. John tells Donna that he needs to borrow some money and Donna agrees. So they arranged to meet in the nearby suburb of Strathfield. Donna tells Colin what's going on and he asks Donna to drop him back at the Regents Park Hotel. He said he'll order some takeaway Chinese food from the bistro for them while she goes and meets John. Donna agreed to that so they go back to the Regents Park Hotel and then Donna goes off to meet her ex husband John.
他们在保龄球俱乐部玩了老虎机，又喝了几杯。没过多久，唐娜接到了前夫约翰的电话。当时约翰带着他们12岁的儿子。约翰告诉唐娜他需要借一些钱，唐娜答应了。于是他们约定在附近的斯特拉斯菲尔德（Strathfield）郊区见面。唐娜把情况告诉了科林，科林要求唐娜顺路把他送回摄政公园酒店。他说，在她去见约翰的时候，他会在小酒馆里为他们点一些中式外卖。唐娜同意了，于是他们回到摄政公园酒店，然后唐娜出发去见前夫约翰。
After her meeting with John where she arranged to pick their son up the next evening Donna returns to the Regents Park Hotel. Colin is waiting at the bar with the Chinese food. They leave together and go back to Donna's house to eat. It's here while they're eating that Colin says Donna got another phone call from an unknown caller. After the call Donna told Colin she had to leave and go and see somebody in Strathfield again. And she had to leave straight away no time to finish dinner. Colin says that's fine but asks if Donna can drop him home on her way. Donna agrees and Colin says he gets home somewhere around 9 or 9.30 PM.
在与约翰见面并安排好第二天傍晚接儿子之后，唐娜回到了摄政公园酒店。科林正带着中餐外卖在吧台等候。他们一起离开，回到唐娜家吃饭。正是在他们吃饭的时候，科林说唐娜接到了另一个未知来电者的电话。电话挂断后，唐娜告诉科林她必须马上离开，再去斯特拉斯菲尔德见一个人。而且她必须马上走，没有时间吃完晚饭。科林说没关系，但问唐娜是否能在路上顺便送他回家。唐娜同意了，科林说他大约在晚上9点或9点30分回到家。
Colin is the last known person to see Donna alive. The next day Wednesday the 3rd of November 1999 John makes a few attempts to call Donna but he can't get a hold of her. Nothing too unusual she's at work so he doesn't think too much of it. But as the morning turned to afternoon and the afternoon turned to evening John started to worry. By evening he still hadn't heard from Donna and that was unusual. Donna should have answered or at least returned his phone calls by now. It was the out of character for her. If she didn't answer she would always ring back.
科林是最后一个见到唐娜还活着的人。第二天，即1999年11月3日星期三，约翰多次尝试给唐娜打电话，但联系不上她。这并不算太寻常，她在上班，所以他没多想。但随着上午变成下午，下午变成傍晚，约翰开始担心起来。到了傍晚，他依然没有唐娜的消息，这就很不寻常了。唐娜本该接电话，或者至少现在已经回电话了。这完全不符合她的性格。如果她不接电话，总是会回电的。
He had their son and he needed to make sure she was still right to picking him up at the time they had arranged the night before. She would always ring the day they were exchanging custody to make sure everything was still right to go ahead. John starts to call friends and family. He calls Donna's mother. She says that she hasn't heard from Donna either. John tries other friends and family without any luck. He rings Donna's mother back and she suggests that John go to Donna's house. She said you'll know if she is home straight away because her car will be parked at the front.
他带着他们的儿子，需要确保她依然能按照前一晚商定的时间接走孩子。每次交换抚养权的当天，她总是会打电话来确认一切是否仍能按计划进行。约翰开始给亲友打电话。他打给唐娜的母亲。她说她也没有唐娜的消息。约翰又联系了其他亲友，但都没有结果。他回电话给唐娜的母亲，母亲建议约翰去唐娜家。她说，只要看看车有没有停在门前，你马上就知道她在家不在。
John drives to Donna's house and their son was still with him. They find Donna's red Mitsubishi Lancer parked out the front under the carport. Their son has a key for Donna's place and so John grabs the key and goes inside. As you walk inside the house there is a bedroom off to the right and the entrance to the lounge room is off to the left. It was here at the entrance to the lounge room that John finds Donna's body. He immediately makes a fintech phone call to Donna's mum and to the police. Police arrive soon after. The house was immediately taped off and a crime scene was established.
约翰开车去唐娜家，他们的儿子仍然和他在一起。他们发现唐娜红色的三菱蓝瑟（Mitsubishi Lancer）停在正门的车棚下。他们的儿子有唐娜家的钥匙，于是约翰拿过钥匙走了进去。一进屋，右边是一个卧室，左边是通往客厅的入口。正是在客厅入口处，约翰发现了唐娜的尸体。他立即给唐娜的母亲和警方打了紧急电话。警察很快赶到。房屋立即被拉起警戒线，并设立了犯罪现场。
Donna was covered in blood. She had multiple stab wounds and her face was badly bruised and swollen. She was naked from the waist down. The lounge room was in complete disarray and it was clear a violent struggle had occurred. There were things all over the place. There was a pillow and a plastic bag located next to her head. Both had blood on them. There was a towel located in the lounge room with blood all over it.
唐娜浑身是血。她有多处刺伤，面部严重瘀伤且肿胀。她腰部以下赤裸。客厅里一片狼藉，很显然这里发生过激烈的搏斗。到处都是东西。她的头部旁边放着一个枕头和一个塑料袋。两者上面都有血迹。客厅里还有一条沾满血迹的毛巾。
The knife was found in the corner of the lounge room with blood on it and the blade had been bent. Such was the ferocious nature of the attack. On the coffee table there were three containers of Chinese food all partly eaten. Next to the Chinese containers were two bowls and a bottle of Tuizbi. On the floor were two spoons, two forks and another bottle of Tuizbi and a can of vodka. There was no sign of forced entry to the house. Police think her attack was very quick over in a matter of minutes. An impulse attack.
凶器是一把刀，上面沾有血迹，刀刃已经弯曲，可见袭击之凶猛。茶几上有三盒中餐外卖，都只吃了一半。中餐盒旁边有两个碗和一瓶Tuizbi。地板上是两个汤匙、两把叉子、另一瓶Tuizbi和一罐伏特加。房子没有遭到强行闯入的迹象。警方认为袭击发生得非常快，在几分钟内就结束了。是一次冲动的袭击。
Donna may not have even had a chance to scream. So the fact that the neighbours said they heard nothing wasn't a great surprise. As police were of the belief there may not have been anything to hear. John was taken back to the police station with his and Donna's son where they were both interviewed. John immediately tells them about Keith, Donna's violent ex-partner. John was well aware of the volatile nature of their relationship. Police interviewed John extensively and traced his movements the previous night and his story checked out. They were able to conclusively say he had nothing to do with her murder.
唐娜甚至可能连尖叫的机会都没有。因此，邻居们说他们什么也没听到也就不足为奇了。因为警方确信当时可能根本没有什么声音可听。约翰和唐娜的儿子被带回警察局，两人都接受了讯问。约翰立即向他们提及了唐娜那有暴力倾向的前男友基思。约翰非常清楚他们关系的动荡本质。警方对约翰进行了广泛的讯问，并追溯了他前一晚的行踪，他的说辞得到了证实。他们能够确凿地证明他与她的谋杀案无关。
Ruling John out put one person straight to the top of the suspect list. Keith Bond. Police pull up Keith's record and see that there was the recent assault charge against Donna and the apprehended violence order application. They say the history of violence throughout the relationship. He immediately becomes the focal point of the police investigation. Detectives visited Keith's house on Amy Street Regions Park at 7 30 a.m. the next morning Thursday the 4th of November 1999. No one was home at this time.
排除了约翰的嫌疑，让一个人直接登上了嫌疑人名单的榜首：基思·邦德。警方调出基思的案底，发现他最近有一项针对唐娜的袭击指控以及限制暴力令的申请。他们指出这段关系中有着暴力史。他立即成为警方调查的焦点。侦探们在第二天清晨，即1999年11月4日星期四上午7点30分，走访了基思位于摄政公园艾米街的住所。当时家里没人。
They knocked on a few neighbours' doors and found that along with his brother Colin a fair man Peter also lived with them. They decided to try again a bit later and left. When they returned a few hours later they were out of luck again with Keith but Colin Bond answered the door. Colin was cooperative and invited the detectives inside. He told them that Keith was at work for the day and their other flatmate Peter wasn't home either. Detectives got talking with Colin and asked if he knew Donna. He said of course Donna was Keith's ex-girlfriend. Colin told police that Keith and Donna used to fight constantly.
他们敲了几个邻居的门，发现除了他弟弟科林，还有一个叫彼得（Peter）的男子也和他们住在一起。他们决定过一会儿再试一次便离开了几小时后他们返回时，依然没能找到基思，不过科林·邦德前来应门。科林很配合，并邀请侦探们进屋。他告诉他们基思白天去上班了，他们的另一个室友彼得也不在家。侦探们与科林交谈，询问他是否认识唐娜。他说当然认识，唐娜是基思的前女友。科林告诉警方，基思和唐娜过去常常不断地吵架。
He felt bad for Donna because of the way Keith treated her. One night got so bad that Colin stepped in and had to punch up with Keith over how he was treating Donna. Detectives asked him when the last time he saw Donna was and he told them about being with her Tuesday night at the Regions Park Hotel. Then they left and had some takeaway Chinese food at her place before Donna got a phone call and had to leave. Well what an answer that was. Colin certainly got the attention of detectives with that one. Colin agrees to go with the detectives back to the station to conduct a recorded interview. He wasn't under arrest, he went voluntarily. He was very cooperative and wanted to help the investigation.
他为唐娜感到难过，因为基思对她不好。有一次情况太糟糕了，科林介入其中，不得不为基思如何对待唐娜而与基思大打出手。侦探们问他上一次见到唐娜是什么时候，他讲述了周二晚上在摄政公园酒店和她在一起的经历。然后他们离开，在她的住处吃了一些中式外卖，之后唐娜接到一个电话不得不离开。哇，这可真是个了不起的回答。科林凭此成功引起了侦探们的注意。科林同意和侦探们一起回局里进行录音讯问。他当时没有被捕，他是自愿前往的。他非常配合，并希望协助调查。
He liked Donna, he wanted to help any way he could. In that interview Colin went back through his evening with Donna. He added in that he had two bottles of to his beer and Donna had a can of vodka and these have been found at the scene by police. He told detectives about the phone call that Donna had gotten while they were eating Chinese food. And she said that she had to leave and go and meet somebody in Ashefield. He says his phone call was somewhere around 8.30 or 9 o'clock p.m. He requested Donna drop him home, which she did. He told them he got home somewhere around 9 or 9.30 p.m.
他喜欢唐娜，想尽自己所能提供帮助。在那次讯问中，科林重新讲述了当晚与唐娜在一起的经过。他补充说，他喝了两瓶同款啤酒，唐娜喝了一罐伏特加，这些都在现场被警方找到了。他向侦探们讲述了唐娜在吃中餐时接到的那个电话。她说她必须离开，去阿什菲尔德（Ashfield）见某个人。他说那个电话大约在晚上8点30分或9点左右。他要求唐娜顺便把他送回家，唐娜照做了。他告诉他们，他大约在晚上9点或9点30分回到家。
He didn't see or hear from Donna again. During this interview something else caught the eye of police. Colin's right hand was very swollen and there was also a cut on a knuckle. But that was easily explained when asked about his hand Colin had this to say. It happened when I was doing the gardening yesterday. I hit a steel pike, the garden hose real thing. Colin was the last known person to see Donna alive so they were very interested in what he had to say. Especially when he admitted going back to her place to eat Chinese food, which police had found half eaten at the scene.
他再没有见过或听说过唐娜。在这次讯问中，另一件事引起了警察的注意。科林的右手非常肿胀，指关节上也有一个伤口。但当被问及他的手时，科林很容易地解释了这一点。这发生在我昨天做园艺的时候。我撞到了一个铁桩，就是连着花园水管的那个东西。科林是最后一个见到唐娜活着的人，因此他们对他的话非常感兴趣。尤其是当他承认回到她家吃中餐时，警方在现场发现了只吃了一半的中餐。
But he was being very cooperative. He was happy to talk to detectives and to help out. Surely it wouldn't be this helpful if he was guilty. And by now police had confirmed that Donna did in fact receive two telephone calls around the time Colin had mentioned. One at 8.30 p.m. the other at 8.39 p.m. Colin was telling the truth about that so there was no reason to believe he was lying about anything else. So who did Donna go and meet? And there was another problem that police had. They still couldn't find Keith.
但他非常配合。他乐于与侦探交谈并提供帮助。如果他有罪，他肯定不会这么乐于助人。而此时，警方已经证实，唐娜确实在科林提到的时间左右接到了两个电话。一个在晚上8点30分，另一个在晚上8点39分。科林在这件事上说了实话，所以没有理由相信他在其他事情上撒谎。那么唐娜去见了谁？警方还遇到了另一个问题。他们仍然找不到基思。
On that day Thursday the 4th of November police conductors search were on at Keith and Colin's place. Not long into the search they noticed a few smears of blood on the floor in the lounge room. But it was easily explained. Both Colin and Keith had recently cut their fingers so the blood could have been either of theirs. A sample was taken to match just in case. The search was extensive and took around four hours. Colin was present at the time of the search and a police officer noticed what looked like a blood smear on his watch. Colin was questioned about it and he says it was probably blood from when he heard he's here in gardening.
在那天，即11月4日星期四，警方对基思和科林的住处执行了搜查令。搜查没多久，他们就注意到客厅地板上有几处血迹。但这也容易解释。科林和基思最近都切伤了手指，所以血迹可能是他们俩任何一人的。为了以防万一，警方提取了样本以作比对。搜查非常彻底，大约持续了四个小时。搜查时科林在场，一名警官注意到他的手表上似乎有血迹。科林受到了盘问，他说这可能是他昨天做园艺时手受伤流出的血。
Police seized the watch for DNA testing. They also took a ring he was wearing on his right hand. Colin was still pretty non-plus, didn't seem too phased. He handed the items over with no complaints. He was happy to help. Unfortunately the DNA tests don't work as quick as the TV shows so police wouldn't have any results back for a few weeks. There was a bit to test too. They had all the bloodstained items found at the scene, the towel, the plastic bag, the knife.
警方扣押了这块手表进行DNA检测。他们还拿走了他戴在右手上的戒指。科林仍然表现得非常淡定，似乎一点也没有慌乱。他毫无怨言地交出了这些物品。他很乐意帮忙。不幸的是，DNA检测不像电视节目里那么快，所以警方几周内都不会有任何结果。需要检测的东西也挺多的。他们有在现场发现的所有沾血物品：毛巾、塑料袋、刀子。
And now these few items from Colin as well as the blood smear on the floor. But detectives couldn't just sit back and wait for the results. They had to keep working at it to see if they could solve it before then. There was one other thing of interest found during the search worm. Underneath Keith's bed there was a wallet. Why was that wallet of interest? Because it was Donna's wallet. Later that day police found Keith.
现在还有科林的这几件物品以及地板上的血迹。但侦探们不能只是坐在那里等待结果。他们必须继续努力，看是否能在之前破案。搜查期间还发现了另一件有趣的东西。在基思的床底下有一个钱包。为什么那个钱包会引起兴趣？因为那是唐娜的钱包。当天晚些时候，警方找到了基思。
Or he found them. He heard police were trying to catch up with him so he presented to the police station himself. He also agreed to be interviewed. In relation to Donna's wallet being found under his bed, Keith said Donna had left it there one night and they broke up not long after that. So he kept it out of spot. He also immediately presented an alibi. He said shortly after breaking up with Donna he started seeing a new girl, Debbie, and he was with her on the night of Donna's death. Keith was up front with detectives about why he had broken up with Donna.
或者说，他找到了他们。他听说警方正在找他，于是主动去了警察局。他也同意接受讯问。关于在床底下发现唐娜钱包一事，基思称唐娜有一天把钱包落在了那里，不久后他们就分手了。所以他就把它收在了一个地方。他还立即提供了不在场证明。他说，与唐娜分手后不久，他开始和一个叫黛比（Debbie）的新女孩交往，在唐娜遇害当晚他和她在一起。关于为什么要和唐娜分手，基思向侦探们坦白了。
He told them about the assault charge. But that's no great surprise. He would have already known that they knew about that. Keith gave the following version of events. On Melbourne Cup Day, Tuesday the 2nd of November 1999, Keith was with his new girlfriend Debbie at the Regents Park bowling club. About 7pm Keith left Debbie at the bowling club to play bingo and he decided to go to the Regents Park hotel. When he got to the hotel he saw Donna and Colin. He noticed that Donna and Colin left soon after.
他告诉了他们袭击指控的事。但这并不令人意外。他肯定已经知道他们知道了这件事。基思给出了以下事件版本：在墨尔本杯赛马日，即1999年11月2日星期二，基思和他的新女友黛比在摄政公园保龄球俱乐部。大约晚上7点，基思离开正在保龄球俱乐部玩宾果游戏的黛比，决定去摄政公园酒店。他到酒店时看到了唐娜和科林。他注意到唐娜和科林不久后就离开了。
Colin returned by himself a bit later on and then Donna returned after that. He said it was about 9pm when Donna returned to the hotel. At this time Keith decided it would be a good time to leave and he went back to the bowling club to see Debbie. They left the bowling club together about 10pm and went straight back to Keith's home where they went to bed together. They arrived home at about 10.30pm. A bit later on Keith heard Colin walk inside and sometime around midnight Keith was woken up by the washing machine. Colin decided it was a good idea to do some washing. Keith wasn't too impressed with this and he got up and had it out with Colin.
科林过了一会儿独自返回，然后唐娜也随之返回。他说唐娜大约在晚上9点回到酒店。此时基思决定这是离开的好时机，于是他回到保龄球俱乐部去找黛比。他们在晚上10点左右一起离开保龄球俱乐部，直接回到基思家上床睡觉。他们大约在晚上10点30分到家。过了一会儿，基思听到科林走进屋里，大约在午夜左右，基思被洗衣机的声音吵醒了。科林决定洗衣服是个好主意。基思对此很不以为然，于是起身和科林大吵了一架。
Keith turned off the washing machine and went back to bed. Keith said he noticed that along with Colin clothes there was also a pair of shoes in the machine. Keith's interview was somewhat similar to Colin's. Colin said in his interview he was with Donna at the Regents Park hotel before leaving for a while to go to the bowling club. That's when Donna got a call from her ex-husband John. Colin went back to the Regents Park hotel and Donna met him back there a bit later on. So their story seemed to match up but there was one important discrepancy. Keith says he got home at about 10.30pm and Colin got home after him.
基思关掉洗衣机，回房继续睡觉。基思说他注意到，除了科林的衣服，洗衣机里还有一双鞋。基思的供述与科林的有些相似。科林在讯问中说，他和唐娜在摄政公园酒店，随后离开了一会儿去了保龄球俱乐部。就在那时，唐娜接到了前夫约翰的电话。科林回到了摄政公园酒店，唐娜过了一会儿也在那儿和他汇合了。所以他们的说辞似乎吻合，但有一个重要的出入。基思说他大约在晚上10点30分到家，科林比他晚到家。
But Colin says he was home by 9.30pm. That was an important difference although it was only an hour. So is it possible that one of the brothers was simply mistaken with their time? And of course there was the other question. What was Colin doing his washing after midnight for? Was this normal? Debbie corroborated Keith's version although she wasn't exactly independent. There wasn't any great shock that she backed up Keith's story.
但科林说他在晚上9点30分就到家了。这是一个重要的差异，尽管只相差一个小时。那么，有没有可能两兄弟中有一个人记错了时间？当然还有另一个问题。科林为什么要在午夜之后洗衣服？这正常吗？黛比证实了基思的版本，尽管她并非完全独立证人。她支持基思的说法并不令人感到意外。
So now who is the number one suspect? We've got Colin washing his clothes after midnight. We've got Keith with Donna's wallet under his bed. We've got a blood smear in their lounge room. And one of them was possibly lying about their movements on the night Donna was murdered and lying about what time they got home. And what about this mystery caller? Who did she go and meet? No matter who detectives thought was responsible there was a difference between believing someone had committed a murder and being able to prove it beyond a reasonable doubt.
那么现在谁是头号嫌疑人？我们有科林在午夜后洗衣服。我们有基思的床底藏着唐娜的钱包。我们有客厅里的血迹。其中一人可能在唐娜被杀当晚的行踪上撒了谎，也对回家的时间撒了谎。那这个神秘来电者呢？她去见了谁？无论侦探们认为谁应当负责，相信某人犯下谋杀罪与能够排除合理怀疑地证明这一点之间，仍然存在着差异。
The police had no witnesses and they still didn't have the DNA results back. They didn't have enough to make a case against anybody just yet. The post-mortem was conducted on Donna on Thursday 5th November 1999. Her facial injuries were extensive and it was determined that they were suffered by the use of extreme force. Death was determined to be due to a combination of severe head trauma and multiple stab wounds. Despite the fact she was naked from the waist down, there was no evidence of sexual assault. As the investigation continued, police find that the two fan calls Donna received the night of her death at 8.30pm and 8.39pm were both from John, her ex-husband. They were the only calls she had answered that night.
警方没有目击者，而且仍然没有拿到DNA检测结果。他们目前的证据还不足以对任何人提起诉讼。1999年11月5日星期四，法医对唐娜进行了尸检。她的面部伤势极其严重，经判定是由极大的暴力造成的。死因被确认为严重头部创伤和多处刺伤的结合。尽管她腰部以下赤裸，但没有性侵的证据。随着调查的继续，警方发现唐娜在遇害当晚8点30分和8.39分收到的两个电话都是她的前夫约翰打来的。那是她当晚唯一接听的电话。
There was no other mysterious caller, no mysterious person she met at Ashfield. John was the only person Donna went out to meet that night. That was significant, as were the DNA results that had come back. The plastic bag located in Donna's lounge room contained a bloody fingerprint. The blood was Donna's, the fingerprint wasn't. And the towel located in the lounge room contained two blood samples. One sample was Donna's, the other blood sample belonged to the same person who waned the fingerprint. Detectives decided it was time to get one of the Bond brothers back into the station for another interview.
没有神秘的来电者，也没有她在阿什菲尔德见到的神秘人。约翰是唐娜当晚唯一外出见的人。这很重要，返回的DNA结果也很重要。唐娜客厅里的塑料袋上有一个带血的指纹。血是唐娜的，但指纹不是。客厅里的毛巾上有两个血样。一个是唐娜的，另一个血样属于留下指纹的那个人。侦探们决定是时候把邦德兄弟中的一人带回警局进行另一次讯问了。
On the 15th of November 1999, Colin Bond was arrested and he was interviewed for a second time. It was here he learned that there was a bloody fingerprint at the same as to him and his blood was also found at the scene. There was more bad news. The blood on his watch that police had seized at the search warrant, that was Donna's blood. But that wasn't enough to convince Colin. He stuck to his story. He was adamant that they were at Donna's house seating Chinese and she got a phone call. When she got that phone call, she said she had to leave to meet somebody in Ashefield and she dropped him home.
1999年11月15日，科林·邦德被捕并接受了第二次讯问。正是在这里，他得知现场不仅有和自己血型相同的带血指纹，还发现了他的血迹。还有更多坏消息。警察在搜查时从他身上扣押的手表上的血，那是唐娜的血。但这些还不足以让科林认罪。他坚持自己的说法。他坚信他们当时在唐娜家吃中餐，然后她接到了一个电话。接到电话后，她说她必须离开去阿什菲尔德见某个人，并且顺路把他送回家。
He again maintained that he got home about 9 or 9.30pm. But there was a problem with this story. Police had a lot more information by now. They were actually able to confirm Keith's story that he got home around 10.30pm and Colin wasn't there. They were able to confirm that Donna didn't answer any phone calls after the 8.39pm call from John. They were able to confirm she had her meeting with John and then returned to Regent's Park Hotel after that. The Chinese meal was bought after Donna's last phone call. Nobody called Donna while Colin was at her house. Donna didn't leave to go and meet her needy body and she definitely didn't drop Colin home about 9.30pm.
他再次坚称自己大约在晚上9点或9点30分到家。但这个说法存在问题。警方现在掌握了更多信息。他们实际上能够证实基思的说法，即他大约在晚上10点30分到家，而当时科林并不在家。他们能够证实唐娜在接完约翰8点39分的电话后没有接听任何电话。他们能够证实她与约翰见了面，之后回到了摄政公园酒店。中餐是在唐娜最后一个电话之后买的。科林在唐娜家时没有人给唐娜打电话。唐娜没有离开去见什么需要的人，也绝对没有在9点30分左右顺路送科林回家。
There was no sign of forced entry to the house. Colin had an injury consistent with punching someone with extreme force. They could prove he was lying. It finally became too much for Colin when detectives asked him if he could again clarify his movements between 9.30pm and 10.30pm. He replied. Colin Bond was charged with a murder of Donna Wheeler. He had tried to cover his tracks once he got home. He washed his clothes and his shoes.
房子没有遭到强行闯入的迹象。科林身上的伤与用极度暴力殴打他人相吻合。他们可以证明他在撒谎。当侦探们要求他再次澄清9点30分到10点30分之间的行踪时，科林终于情绪崩溃了。他回答道。科林·邦德被控谋杀唐娜·惠勒。他到家后曾试图掩盖行踪。他洗了自己的衣服和鞋子。
He had a shower. But what happened was he took his watch off to have the shower, not realising there was a blood spec on the watch. But at the end of the day, the watch was just another string to the bow. The bloody fingerprint and his blood at the scene were more than enough to charge him. Colin Bond stood trial in June 2001. Colin's defence team had a little glimmer of hope to work with. Keith was subpoenaed to attend court and give evidence, but he refused. He didn't comply with the subpoena and he went into hiding.
他洗了个澡。但实际情况是，他为了洗澡把手表摘了下来，却没有意识到表上有一个血斑。但说到底，这块手表只是众多证据中的又一环。带血的指纹和现场的血迹完全足以起诉他。科林·邦德于2001年6月出庭受审。科林的辩护团队有一线希望可以利用。基思被传唤出庭作证，但他拒绝了。他没有遵守传唤并躲藏了起来。
This gave the defence team their opportunity. They worked hard the entire trial to say that Keith was the killer. After all, he was the one with the history of violence against Donna. They tried to put that doubt in the jury's mind. They only needed to convince one that Keith was on the run because he was guilty. On the 29th of June, the jury retired to reach a verdict. They didn't take them all. They were back very quickly. Colin Bond was found guilty of murder and sentenced to 30 years in jail with a non-parallel period of 25 years.
这给辩护团队提供了机会。他们在整个审判过程中竭力宣称基思才是凶手。毕竟，他是那个对唐娜有暴力史的人。他们试图在陪审团心中种下这种怀疑。他们只需要说服一个人相信基思在逃跑是因为他有罪。6月29日，陪审团退庭商议裁决。他们并没有花太长时间。他们很快就回来了。科林·邦德被判谋杀罪名成立，判处30年监禁，其中25年不得假释。
When the finding was read out, Donna's mother yelled at Colin to rot in hell. He just clad at her with a smug, arrogant look. He was sent to Lithgow jail to serve out his sentence. There's no doubt Colin killed Donna. But in case for some reason one of the jurors had some lingering doubt, or in case anyone listening has a doubt, the crown prosecutor took the unusual step of requesting that the jury stay in the courtroom while Colin's criminal record was read. They got to hear about a murder Colin had previously committed
当判决宣读完毕时，唐娜的母亲对科林大喊让他烂死在地狱里。他只是带着一副自鸣得意、傲慢的表情斜视着她。他被送往利思戈监狱（Lithgow jail）服刑。毫无疑问，是科林杀害了唐娜。但为了以防万一某些陪审员仍心存疑虑，或者任何听众心存疑虑，皇家检察官采取了一个不同寻常的举措，要求陪审团留在法庭里，同时宣读科林的犯罪记录。他们得以听到科林以前曾犯下的一起谋杀案，
that bore a chilling resemblance to the murder of Donna Wheeler. In 1987, Colin Bond attacked a woman. According to Colin, it went like this. With a few beers under my belt, I got the shits and hit her. That was a gross under-exaggeration. The woman's face was beaten to a bloody pulp. He left her for dead, taking off her pants, leaving her naked from the waist down. She died 16 days later as a result of those sickening facial injuries.
该案与唐娜·惠勒谋杀案有着令人不寒而栗的相似之处。1987年，科林·邦德袭击了一名女子。据科林描述，当时情况是这样的。喝了几杯啤酒后，我很不爽，就打了她。这绝对是轻描淡写。那个女人的脸被打得血肉模糊。他把她等死般地扔在那里，脱掉了她的裤子，让她腰部以下赤裸。16天后，她因这些令人作呕的面部伤情而死亡。
Police at the time were of the opinion that the woman had rejected Colin's sexual advances, so he snapped and bludgeoned her to death. Police were of the opinion that's exactly what happened with Donna. Colin made sexual advances towards her that she rejected. Somehow, Colin was able to plead that first murder charged down a manslaughter and was sentenced to 20 years jail with a non-parole period of 10 years. Of course, he only served a minimum 10 years and was out of jail less than 12 months before he killed Donna Wheeler. Imagine if the courts had have imposed a proper sentence.
当时的警方认为，该女子拒绝了科林的性骚扰，于是他情绪失控，将其殴打致死。警方认为唐娜案的情况完全一样。科林对她进行性骚扰遭到了拒绝。不知怎么的，科林竟然成功将第一起谋杀指控辩诉降格为了过失杀人，并被判处20年监禁，其中10年不得假释。当然，他只服刑了最低的10年，出狱不到12个月就杀害了唐娜·惠勒。试想一下，如果法院当时判处了适当的刑期，
Donna Wheeler might still be alive today. And of course, this information couldn't be brought up during Colin's trial, as it would have been unfair to him if the jury had knowledge of that previous charge. Donna and her mother were both aware that Colin had been in jail for killing a woman. Donna's mum told her to be very careful hanging around him. But Donna believed the story that Colin had told her about her. His explanation to Donna was that he became involved in a heated argument with the girl and he pushed her over. When she fell, she hit her head and died.
唐娜·惠勒今天可能还活着。当然，这些信息在科林的审判期间是不能被提出来的，因为如果陪审团知道此前的指控，对他就很不公平了。唐娜和她的母亲都知道科林曾因杀害一名女性而入狱。唐娜的妈妈告诉她，和这种人混在一起要格外小心。但唐娜相信了科林对她讲述的关于那件事的版本。他对唐娜的解释是，他当时与那个女孩发生了激烈的争吵，然后把她推倒了。她摔倒时撞到了头部，不幸身亡。
It was all an accident according to him. I guess the light sentence Colin got fell in line with that story, so I can see why Donna might have believed it. If only she knew the truth. Colin ended up dying of a heart attack a few years into his 30 year sentence. But just think, he had already committed two sickening murders, but he still would have been eligible for parole in his late 70s. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
据他说，这一切都是一场意外。我猜科林得到的轻判与那个说法吻合，所以我能理解为什么唐娜可能会相信它。要是她知道真相就好了。在30年刑期过去几年后，科林最终死于心脏病发作。但试想一下，他已经犯下了两起令人作呕的谋杀案，却依然有资格在七十多岁时获得假释。您还没有对本剧集发表评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。